what is that toxicity somehow going to
go away but that's a strong man because
no one says there's anything toxic about
masculinity per se what do you mean no
one says that people the term exists
exists strong man what what I like don't
even know that's that's the biggest
gender like identity flip was him saying
things that don't make sense what up
guys welcome to the judge pearly things
YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series today I am going to be
reacting to Jordan Peterson talking
about how he is not an anti-feminist
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in let's get
started all I would say is that
um I'm not anti-feminist per se I mean I
think the idea that
the world would benefit from the
movement of talent from both sexes into
the workplace as rapidly as possible is
something that anyone with any sense
should share given the rather the Rarity
of talent and the necessity for for
utilizing it
um I do stand by my original statement
though that there's a brand of more
radical feminism that that insists that
our culture is best characterized as an
oppressive patriarchy and I think that
first of all that that's an appalling
sociological Doctrine and I think it has
very negative psychological effects and
they won't be limited to men because ins
if it's true that there's something
toxic let's say about masculinity per se
what that will inevitably mean is that
as women adopt more masculine roles
traditionally what is that toxicity
somehow going to go away but that's a
strong man because no one says there's
anything toxic about masculinity per se
what do you mean no one says that people
the term exists
about forms of masculinity that are
harmful to men and women it's not about
masculinity per se you must know that I
read the American yeah but where is
toxic femininity and the funny thing is
everything they they deem is like
toxically masculine it literally is just
things that men do
like they'll say oh why don't men talk
about their feelings because that's what
women do we talk talk we just talk about
our feelings blah blah blah blah blah
men don't do that that's not how men are
and so it's just asking men to be women
and they're not women and then they
Gaslight you know women are the biggest
gaslighters women say men Gaslight us
but women Gaslight because what they'll
do is they'll say oh
um I'm not shooting on masculinity per
se after they spend an hour talking
about how much they hate men I mean I'm
paraphrasing you know but I mean let's
just call it what it is yeah
Psychological Association guidelines for
the treatment of poison men and I know
perfectly well that this is no strong
strong man and it's not only devoted
towards what you might describe as the
more aggressive ends of masculine
Behavior it's aimed at at masculinity in
a much broader you know much broader
range of there's a much broader range of
accusations that are underlying that are
under the surface than that and so I
don't see in what way at all that it's a
strong okay I'm just going to pull is
that uh go to uh Catherine McGregor and
Catherine I mean you've you've lived on
both sides of the Gen defense so um what
are your thoughts on on these issues and
just get back to the question I don't
know whether that qualifies me or
disqualifies me frankly
sorry guys I ratted on the team but not
because
yeah let's just get a tranny's opinion
yes super mentally stable all right all
right theological reasons intensely
personal I gather we might address that
but look I I'm not entirely out of
sympathy with Jordan's critique I I
I'm the oldest person on this panel by
you Tony and in my lifetime I've
I've seen uh
you know rolling institutional crises
through the West you know the Great
American settlement based on Bretton
Woods and NATO and the United Nations
and so on is fraying globally in the
area that I can talk about with some
Authority we're seeing a dissolving
Global Order now with the rise of two
autocratic totalitarian capitalist
states which is replicating the
conditions of the 1930s and I gather
we're not doing the ga strategic stuff
but I think it's very alarming
when Robert F Kennedy who was my
political hero
was running for the presidency of the
United States in 1968.
he addressed disenfranchised African
Americans
who were wearing the backlash from from
many white men who were losing their
jobs or perceiving that they were losing
their jobs
the de-industrialization of the West as
as jobs are exported to the developing
world all of these factors are Bobby
Kennedy said it wasn't Jermaine Greer
that said it he said when you remove
from the man the right to stand before
his family as a breadwinner and people
will say that's patriotic that's your
minute by the way so all right well I'll
shut up but
that
is it just me or did she like not hear
the question or he yeah no that's what I
was thinking I was like what what are
you talking about it's like even men
that pretend to be women just say things
that make no sense
that's that's the biggest gender like
identity flip was him saying things that
don't make sense of meaningful work
amongst especially unskilled men has a
political consequence and it's been
washing through the American System
since 1980 with the Reagan democrats the
Frank of the New Deal coalition
I don't entirely agree with Jordan's
analysis but the problem can't be gain
saved and three million books later in
50 languages or whatever it is I bought
your book by the way and you're out
selling yeah there's a mental issue
somewhere there and warned now that's a
culturally specific reference that
Delights me in two ways of course in
Australian cricket no one has more
bleached blonde hair or has had more
work done than I but one is a close
second
we should put that out on Twitter but
what what I like don't even know
like okay seriously but this is like the
delusion nobody on the stage says what
are you talking about you see what I
mean like I'm even surprised that Jordan
didn't like it was you should have been
like what yeah what are you talking
about and and the crazy thing is it's
like the men pretending to be women then
get the I get to live in delusion path
yes yes it's all delusion I just want to
live in reality I want to live in what
the world is and I don't know even what
Jordan was saying in the beginning about
like utilizing women's talents I I don't
think that's necessarily like a bad
thing however I do think it downplays
how much nonsense women like bring into
the workforce with our HR that we don't
need with these basically useless jobs
and that we're overpaid for by taking
money from the men but that's a whole
other conversation that I will get into
yes I think women's jobs are pretty much
much useless
um I think that yeah nurses do well but
then it's like every job that we have we
all complain about those Industries so
are we really like bringing our talents
to the workforce maybe we can look
pretty and talk but like come on anyways
you know let me know in the comments
what you guys think um subscribe to the
channel bring that notification Bell and
I'll talk to you next time